JENNY BROWN: Hiring great people
is core to every business,
but finding the right talent
is often the tricky part.
Traditional job
sites aim to help
people find jobs
and jobs find people
but can have difficulty
returning relevant results.
Let's dive into how you can
use Google's Cloud Talent
Solution to leverage
machine learning
and create a better
job search experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
See, large companies may have
their own internal hiring
and recruiting teams, whereas,
smaller companies might
use off-the-shelf
talent solutions,
but both want quality results
for candidates and job
postings.
Trying to match these
together may sound simple
on the surface, but traditional
keyword searching is
too simplistic and
gets choked up in some
situations, such as hidden or
extraneous keywords, also known
as keyword stuffing;
job postings
that require five
years of experience
in a technology that's really
only been around for two years;
and things like typos,
acronyms, and overuse
of technical jargon.
What exactly is a [? rec ?] and
asset prot [? 1? ?] Ultimately,
these lead to poor experiences
and bad candidate fits.
So Google used
machine learning, also
called ML, to create a
customizable job searching
experience.
The Cloud Talent
Solution job search
API is designed to
power the job search
experience with built-in
machine learning algorithms.
In short, you send your
job listing information
over, such as the
company and job details,
to the job search API.
The API analyzes the
job data to develop
an understanding of the jobs.
Once jobs have been
indexed by the API,
you can search against the
jobs and get search results
by relevance or other
sorting preferences,
which we'll talk about
in future videos.
There are four common
use cases that typically
leverage a solution like this--
job boards where the
site returns a list
of jobs to job seekers,
career site providers that
provide career site services
to client companies,
staffing agencies which provide
short or long-term employees
to clients, and applicant
tracking systems which
are used by companies to track
applicants through the hiring
process.
The job search API is designed
to be modified to best fit
with your needs, and
the API's performance
can vary significantly based
on how it's configured.
Also, it's worth noting that
the job search API is not
to be confused with
the jobs indexing
API that facilitates
jobs showing up
on google.com Search.
There's a separate indexing API
to have job listings show up
on searches that people
make on google.com.
There's a link for this
in the description,
if you want to learn
more about that,
but the Cloud Talent
Solution job search API
does much more when it's
integrated into your job search
solution.
With all that being
said, let's talk
about how to actually
implement the job search API.
In our next video,
we'll go over the API
in greater detail,
planning steps,
and talk more about
implementation strategies.
Thanks for watching,
and remember,
when looking for talent, it's OK
to keep your head in the cloud.